all right Deanna
Deanna uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Fort
Lauderdale Florida
and tell me about your family growing up
uh my family growing up was very
complicated
um basically I went into the Foster
system at Birth meaning
um when I was born my biological mother
had
already made the decision to you know
leave me at the hospital so I went right
into foster care
and the first foster family that I went
to ended up being my permanent family
they I was the middle child of
seven kids so they had three previous I
was the fourth and then they adopted
three more after me
um as well as continuing to be foster
parents so
my childhood was very
secluded very
um
like stressful because there was just
always so much happening
um a lot of things I didn't realize
until I was older how messed up they
they were because basically
the best way I can describe it is almost
like a cult like we weren't allowed out
of the house really we had no friends
um we barely saw any other family
members we were just kind of like kept
in the house at all times with
um you know our brothers and sisters and
like any other fostered children that
were constantly coming and going coming
and going
um I would say that my adopted mother
pretty much I had we had you know
adopted mom and dad but I would say my
adopted mother pretty much ran the show
um my adopted dad owned a flower shop so
he you know he had his own business so
he wasn't home a lot um especially
during the day so we were home with her
all day and she never worked a day in
her life and
um basically she would sleep all day and
we would have to
kind of look after our brothers and
sisters and you know the other foster
children and um
I don't remember a lot of my younger
years I do know that they
I was their foster child for a year and
then they decided to adopt me when I was
like one years old
[Music]
um
my adopted mother was kind of like a
borderline hoarder so there was just
clutter everywhere
um I would say the first 10 years of my
life I didn't even have my own bedroom
because it was so full of clever there
was no room for for me to be in there
and she had like um these dogs and she
wouldn't walk them so there was
constantly
um feces and pee everywhere and so the
house just it stunk you know to high
heaven to this day like if I smell that
it triggers me
um
and so it was just very chaotic
um along with that
we really weren't educated
um I was sent to school initially
um I went into kindergarten and I guess
um I wasn't like really ready and I
would just like sit and cry so they took
me out of school for a year and then put
me back in
um they put me in a private school
um a private Christian School and
religion's gonna play a part and I don't
remember when religion became such a
huge part of their lives but they put me
in a private Christian school and I was
um the only like person of color in the
school so I was bullied a lot I didn't
look like the other girls
um
my parents my adopted parents are um
white which I don't think I mentioned so
my mom didn't know what to do with my
hair so I had this crazy hair and all
the other girls like had this long
beautiful silky hair and I was darker
than them and I just I didn't fit in so
um not only that my adopted mom like
when I got older I would ask like why do
I look different from you guys and
things like that and she would say oh
like um your parents were like well for
the longest time they didn't even tell
me I was a doctor which I I don't know
why you aren't honest about that and
then they would tell me oh your parents
are um like one of your parents is like
Indian or something like that when in
reality you know I I'm biracial I have a
black uh a biological black dad and a
biological um white mom and they like
hid that from me so which as a kid when
I found out that's what I really was I
was like you know is that something I
should have been ashamed of
um
and if that's the case why would you
adopt you know black or you know
biracial children like if you can't
teach them to be proud of who they are
so that was like a whole thing
um
things really got bad when
um I was assaulted in the school
um one of the bullies had literally
taken I don't know why it was on the
playground but one of the bullies had
taken like one of those two by fours it
went up into a playhouse and like threw
it down on my head and it fell on my
head and I was knocked out I had to go
to the hospital I had a concussion so at
that point they took me
um out of that school and just never put
me back in school
so that's when
homeschooling was very popular so they
said they were going to homeschool all
of us so after that none of the kids in
the
um the house went to school
so we became even more isolated
and
you know it made it easy for them to
like hide all the abuse that was going
on as well
um
some of the things I witnessed living in
that house like I I have horrible PTSD
from
um
I I wouldn't have time to to talk about
all of it but
um some things I remember are my my
especially my my adopted mom like I said
she ran the show she was very
narcissistic very controlling and when
the kids started to Rebel or they
weren't doing what they were told
um she would do everything from you know
beating the crap out of them there was a
time when
she had my adopted Dad hold down my
older adopted sister and she like put a
lighter to her face and like acted like
she was gonna burn her
um
things like that happened all the time
um I would say one of the worst things
that ever happened was
after me they adopted um
they adopted another uh girl um she was
also biracial because then they decided
that they didn't want me to feel like
the outcast in the family so they wanted
me to have a biracial sister
so they adopted her and then they
adopted two more children
um who were half brothers and
half-sister all the rest of us had um
were not like blood related whatsoever
and the little girl had a lot of
Behavioral issues because she came from
she was abused and she came from you
know a bad um a bad home which is why
you know she went into the system not
you know not to continue to be abused
and so she would act out a lot and one
day I guess my adopted mom was so like
sick of um her behavior that she took
her hands
and ran them under
um hot running water
and I guess she didn't realize how hot
it really was because her skin started
to literally melt off and
um once she realized the damage that she
had done she wasn't going to you know
take her to the hospital because what
was going to happen you know they're
gonna ask what happened and then you
know obviously she would have been in
trouble for that so she had me and one
of my older sisters run to Walgreens and
get all kinds of bandages and um you
know ointments and stuff and so we had
to bandage her up and clean her wounds
every day and like that little girl
crying because she was in so much pain
it was so heartbreaking her hands um you
know when when I burned that bad he was
like it goes to all different stages at
one point her hands were so swollen up
that they were on right like you
couldn't even tell they were hands
anymore and um I'm shocked that she did
not get an infection but
um she did eventually heal and
she's um she's always had you know she's
had scars from that obviously and the
messed up part is my adopted mom was
such a narcissist and such a
like she would she never um would admit
to anything that she did so
even as an adult my sister has those
scars and she says oh she came with
those scars like she always had those
those happened like you know before she
came to us like she would never admit to
anything she did
um
there was a lot of abuse going on in the
home even things that I didn't know
about but she did and she continued to
allow it to happen I always thought it
was strange that they Mike my adopted
parents never slept in the same bed
um my adopted dad would sleep on the
couch she would sleep in the bed I
actually the first several years of my
life had to kind of share a bedroom with
my adopted mom because like I said there
wasn't any room in my room because she
you know had it all hoarded up and um
then you know another thing that really
bothers me is that some of the kids
would try to speak out about the abuse
and
um because they were foster parents we
would have visits we would have they
would have like check-ins with them and
stuff and they were made by my adopted
parents to lie to not say what was going
on or to you know if they something had
been reported to them they would you
know make them downplay it um
and so no one ever really knew what was
going on
um and then my parents got into church
and
the church
um
once again because my my mom was such a
narcissist she always had to when we
would join a church she had to feel
special like she loved that she had all
these adopted kids and foster kids
um because people looked at her like oh
my God like look at this amazing person
who's helping these kids and giving them
a better life and everything like that
because they had no idea what was going
on in the home and so um
she would uh she would always have to be
something specific in the church like a
Sunday school teacher and she would
always want to have like a key to the
church and things like that and um when
like some churches that was fine like
they were fine with that and then there
were other churches that kind of saw
through her and they wouldn't give her
all these privileges so as soon as she
stopped feeling like she was being
treated like she was special we would
have to leave and go to another church
um
and the churches were just kind of
getting more and more radical where
every time we acted out it was because
there was like an evil spirit in us and
they had to like cast the the spirit out
of us and all these things and then
you'd go to church and um you know they
would lay hands on you and if you didn't
like feel something and like fall down
like everyone looked at you like there
was something wrong with you and
it was just ridiculous and then um the
fact that nobody had any idea what was
going on in our home and they really
thought that this was such an amazing
family that should be looked up to
um was just it was just crazy because
they had you know they had no idea
now mind you because we didn't go to
school we didn't have any friends I had
such
um horrible social anxiety because I
didn't know how to act around kids my
age
so um I felt like I kind of got bullied
a lot in church and I never felt like I
belonged and even in church like we were
watched by my parents every second so
even if I tried to kind of go off with
the other kids my age like I would get
called back like no you can't you know
you can't be with them you need to be
where I can see you you know and I'm at
this point I'm like you know 12 13 14
you know and up and it you know it was
embarrassing so I just felt so isolated
so I got to the point in my life where
I just I wouldn't talk like I didn't
talk to anyone
um I became very quiet very withdrawn
because I figured if I don't talk I
can't say the wrong thing and no one can
make fun of me because I didn't I truly
didn't know how to socialize
um
and so that was kind of like how how we
grew up
um the homeschooling thing just we we
really were not educated
um the only reason I even knew how to
read is because of um being taught when
I at the time I was in school my younger
siblings
um they they couldn't read for the
longest time because my adopted mom
literally just didn't care you know she
slept all day uh got up around one
o'clock to watch soap operas
um my adopted dad was in you know
working all day like I said and so it
was just a very lonely chaotic
um childhood you know basically
um
the abuse you've described is mainly for
your siblings yes was there anything
that was directed at you not a lot of it
because I think I was
um so scared and so timid that I never
rebelled like they had no reason to
really abuse me
um it was the ones that would kind of
like Rebel and act out
um I would get you know put down a lot I
would get
um called names and things like that and
uh
whenever I would another thing that
really bothered me is um as I got older
you know it's natural to want to know
where you come from and so I would ask
my doctor mom like you know can you know
anything about my you know my mom or my
dad or anything and instead of like
trying to help me or like encouraging me
to um find out where I come from she
would say well haven't we been good
enough parents to you why do you want to
know that she left you at the hospital
why do you care you know so
I learned to just stop asking
um and I think just because I was always
shut down
and um
never taught to like be proud of who I
was or anything like I just I literally
just became like depressed and I would
stay in my room as much as possible like
I think I spent most of my childhood and
um teen years just in my room all alone
unless I had to you know help with the
the children
um
and so I I've never been in person that
had like good self-esteem or self-worth
or felt confidence because I was never
you know taught to be and I was
basically taught to kind of be ashamed
of who I was
um even when we would visit I remember
so vividly we would go visit my adopted
mom's parents they live in Ocala Florida
which is very country very rural very
racist so we weren't allowed to play in
the like me and my younger sister who
were biracial were not allowed to play
outside because they didn't want the
neighbor seeing us because what would
the neighbors think to see these little
black children in their yard
so um basically we were just raised to
not feel good about ourselves or
anything so
um there was also and and I I'll get
into this later because I didn't find
out till later
um my adopted dad who I loved very much
um I had a closer relationship with him
um because he wasn't
to the outside he wasn't evil like my
adopted mom
uh I found out that he had been sexually
abusing my brothers and sisters um
as well as like you know the foster
children that would come and go
and that really
it made me hate my
I know hates a strong word but it really
um made me even more disgusted with my
adopted mom because she knew and because
she wanted to
um have this pretend family where she
was this amazing woman that you know
adopted all these kids and fostered all
these kids she let it continue because
um you know she she just it was more
important to her to you know to look
good and in all these things than um to
protect the children which is if you're
a foster friend that's what you're
supposed to do
um but that didn't I didn't personally
find out about that until many years
later
um
so to kind of
skip ahead so that you know that was
basically my childhood then we get to
I'm probably about 17 or 18. and one of
our like outings when we actually did
get to go out of the house would be to
like Walmart
um or like the mall we did go on
vacations you know here and there
so I met my
future husband at Walmart he was working
there
so that's where um I met Eugene who
would eventually be my future husband
um
we started like chatting and I snuck in
my phone number and I would basically
like um sneak on the phone to to call
him because we weren't you know dating
was out of the question talking to boys
without the question anything involving
sex was we were never taught about it it
was just no that's evil if you do that
that's dirty that's wrong you'll go to
hell like so I didn't know anything
about any of that so
um he seemed like my knight in Charming
Shining Armor like he was charming and I
thought he was good looking and he was
smart and funny and sweet and all these
things
and so
um I immediately like you know was
hooked and uh so I would have to kind of
sneak and call him when I could and then
eventually
um by then I was kind of turning 18 and
the thing with my adopted mom is as
controlling as she was when we got older
and really um she knew she couldn't
really control us anymore she would kind
of lose interest in US honestly and
kind of like let us do our thing
so I start him and I started dating and
um I all the red flags that you see as a
as a adult now like I I didn't see them
then also because
um I truly
you can be naive but for me I truly
didn't know because I had never been out
in the world before so anything you
could have told me he could have told me
that he works on a unicorn farm and I
would have you know believed him
and so um in the beginning
um everything was great and then
he started immediately being very
possessive like right off the bat like
after our like first or second date he
was telling me he loved me and he didn't
want me you know want me to be with
anyone else like very very possessive
and um
so I was like in heaven like I thought
you know I found this amazing guy I'm
gonna get out of this house like I'm
gonna live this happy life and
everything so
turns out that he had a girlfriend that
he was living with her name was Debbie
and him and Debbie were high school
sweethearts
um he's a few years older than me so
when we met I was 16 17 he was like
around 19.
and so they had been high school
sweethearts they lived together they had
like a whole life together and of course
he did not tell me about this
um she eventually found out and
contacted me and was like listen like
this is my boyfriend we live together
we've been together through high school
um
you know she was angry of course and I
don't blame her and she told me
um
you know basically she told me like
you seem like a nice person but like
this is who he is he's cheated on me all
through high school
um he's abusive he's a liar you can't
trust him
um you know all these things and
um
when I confronted him about it of course
he lied and said that
um that was his ex-girlfriend and like
um they were living together because
like she wouldn't leave but like they
weren't together anymore and he didn't
love her and you know all the things
that you know people like to say
um
it turns out that he was an even bigger
narcissist than my mother
um which is I guess everything comes
full circle so
uh we continue dating she continued
Debbie continued to contact me and
um at this point she was like angry
because she's like you know I warned you
like you know I was respectful enough to
like come to you and be respectful and
tell you what's going on
um you can be respectful enough to stay
away from him basically and so
sadly her and I would end up fighting
over him like all the time and it was so
ridiculous and I look back at it now and
I can't believe that
you know I that I was a part of that um
and so he would basically go back and
forth between us
um this went on for a really long time
there were times when I would get sick
of it
um and I would leave him and I would
kind of date other people but he just
the thing you have to understand about
narcissists is that they're very
charming and they're very
um
manipulating and they can make you you
know believe anything that they say so
he would come back with more promises
and I would take him back and we'd get
back together and it would just be the
same cycle over and over again
eventually
uh Debbie got pregnant
and they ended up having
um a son together
and that really really broke my heart
because I at that time I'm like I was
starting to like realize like this is a
game he's not gonna change
um if he really wanted to be with me and
get out of this relationship and this
they would not be having a kid together
so um I left him for a while
um
and then I got sucked back in and by
this time
um Debbie had had it like she was she
was done with him and she ended up
leaving and moving um to Wisconsin where
she still lives and just like she took
their son started a whole other life
and so in my head
um still being naive I thought oh my god
well this is great like
now I have Malta myself and we can
finally have this life that I imagine
for us to have
so we ended up getting married in
2003 so at this point I was probably
like 21 22.
so we get married
and
in the beginning you know things were
good but then
he just
everything that he had done to her he
was doing to me so he was cheating on me
constantly
um
La you know lying about what time he'd
get off work he would just disappear
after work
um the the cheating was just not you
know non-stop
um when I would catch him in lies he
would make me feel like I was crazy
um if I had hard evidence he would uh
still deny it right to my face like he
he would Gaslight me so much that I
thought I was losing my mind
along with dealing with these things
um
because I was so dependent on him
he like he used he used the fact that I
didn't want to be with you know he knew
I didn't want to go back to my family's
house he knew I didn't have any other
family to depend on he knew I didn't
really have a lot of friends so
narcissists love people like that
because they can control them and
manipulate them and no matter what they
do to them they know that you're
dependent on them so they they fully use
that to your advantage to their
advantage
and so um
Not only was all this going going on he
constantly
berated me in public
um would talk down to me would mock me
um
it was okay for him to like if he felt
like if he wanted to compliment me and
tell me I look beautiful or anything
that was fine
but if he felt like
I was feeling like confident on a
certain day or you know maybe I was
looking at myself in the mirror for too
long
um he would make sure to say things like
oh you know who are you putting all that
makeup on for like that looks ridiculous
like who are you trying to look good for
um
he's told me uh
uh and I guess like I said it it all
ties in because he also kind of taught
me to be ashamed of what I of what I am
so he would tell me things like oh okay
okay so um he's uh African-American so
he would tell me things like you know
don't ever think that you're special or
better than anyone else because you know
you're mixed or you're half white like
you're not better than anyone else
um
whenever um
we were
uh we you know we could be out to dinner
with friends and things like that and he
would like mock me and
sorry he would mock me he would um
make fun of like my little routines that
I had sound like a very routine person
so he would like do impressions of me
and like you know other people probably
thought it was like funny and he was
like joking but you know he was
literally mocking me in front of people
um
even his mom
was awful to me she would make fun of
the way I spoke because I guess I spoke
to properly
um she would call me white girl as if
that's supposed to be some type of
insult
um
she I used to be very sickly and she
told me that's because you're not
supposed to mix the Bloods
um so when you know people intertwine
and mix it makes um
I guess it makes a weaker person so
that's why you're not supposed to do
that
um
whenever anyone would say anything nice
to me or compliment me she would like
Snicker like you know
um
so between him and his you know Mom and
the family I had I basically like had
the worst self-esteem self-worth of of
anyone
um
I had like no you know no self value and
um the cheating continued
um
it got to the point where like the girls
that he because the thing is with him
um and I think a lot of narcissists is
that they they love attention and so
they're not going to just go and just
cheat on you with some random random
person they're not it's not going to be
a one and done type of thing they
literally live double lives and so he
would um just like he did to me he would
tell these girls that he was cheating on
me with like I don't really want to be
with her we're going to separate you
know you're the one I want to be with so
um he would like manipulate them and
then they would see that um you know he
wasn't going to leave me and then they
would go crazy and start harassing me
so I would just
um be trying to live and work and you
know just live my life and I'd be
getting phone calls some you know these
girls like telling me Oh you know I was
with your man last night and you know he
says he doesn't love you and you know he
says all these awful things about you
and you know you know whatever
so
um I was constantly being harassed by
all these women that he had manipulated
um so I had I was
I was not happy in life um I was
miserable and full of Stress and Anxiety
constantly
um
by this time I had
made oh I had
a little bit I'm sorry let me back up a
little bit before we got married I had
gone back to
the
um
they Foster not the um sorry the what is
it called the adoption agency where I
was adopted from
um because I wanted to see if they could
find anything out about my mom for me
um and I was really lucky because the
woman who handled my adopt my personal
adoption was still working there and was
like literally a month out from her
retirement
and so she spoke with me and she said um
you know I can't tell you anything pers
you know personally but what I can do is
I'll take down your information I do
know who your grandmother is and I will
try to contact her
and so she did that for me
and
um
so after that my mom ended up reaching
out to me and I was so excited
um I was so happy and she lived in Lake
Placid Florida which was about three
three hours
from where I was living and um
so we made arrangements like a week or
two later to for me to go out there and
meet the family and spend the day with
them and everything and
so me and Eugene went and um
I got to meet her I got to meet my
grandparents
um a half sister
um my aunt my cousin a few other family
members
and um
I talked there was a point when
my mom took me because I lived on like
this beautiful lake so she took me out
to the lake and uh
she asked me if I had had a good life
and I said I did because I didn't want
her to be like I didn't want her to feel
bad so I told her yeah I had a you know
a great life and you know my adopted
family is great and everything because I
did not want to hurt her I wanted to I
didn't want her to regret what she did
because I I knew she was she did what
she thought she you know what what was
best
um
and uh she asked about my dad I mean no
sorry I asked about my dad and uh she
said that um she had tried to reach out
to him when when I reached out to her
and unfortunately he had um
passed away uh several years ago his
family told her so um I didn't ever get
to meet my biological dad
um
but my my biological mom had a um a
really big substance abuse problem
um she was
on and off drugs in and out of rehab
most of her life
um
she had even been you know arrested a
few times
um she had done prostitution to feel her
habits
um apparently she even
when she was pregnant with me my biology
my dad had gotten to some type of
accident and he was in the hospital
and she was so high even while she was
pregnant with me that she went to the
hospital and like tried to unplug him
from like the machines and like kill him
in the hospital like she she had a
chaotic life so I can imagine like she
you know she thought she was doing the
best thing for me by giving me up for
adoption
but at that point she was doing better
she was you know working
um her family had um purchased her a
home like right next to Bears so they
could kind of keep an eye on her even
though you know she's a grown woman at
this point
so but even that day
I don't know if it was just because I
was overwhelmed or excited or you know
what I I ended up not feeling well so I
wanted to to lay down and so
my ex-husband goes to go in the room
with me and my mom was like no no I got
it I'll sit with her you know whatever
he got so angry and was like who does
she think she is I've been the one
taking care of you all this time she
gave you she left you at the hospital
who was she to tell me like even then
like he had to make it about himself
because he felt like he wasn't in
control because he had to be in control
at all times of everything
so
um so that was great
[Music]
um
we said we would keep in touch and you
know she was going to make plans to come
visit me
and everything so I uh you know I went
back home and we would talk on the phone
here and there she would make plans to
come visit me
um and then it just wouldn't happen um
she wouldn't show up
and um I it got to the point where I
felt like that little kid you see on TV
where they're they're doing a play and
they look out in the audience for their
their parent to be there and they never
show up that's how it was feeling
because she did it to me so many times
um
so after a while I just
I couldn't take the disappointment
anymore of
um
her making promises and not coming
through that I just kind of stopped
reaching out
um I kept in contact with my aunts and
my cousin and my grandparents
um
but I just kind of I realized we were
never going to have the relationship
that I wanted with her so I kind of had
to like
you know put that to the back of my mind
um
so Ben not long after that I ended up
getting pregnant with
um with my daughter
and um I was so miserable in my life in
my marriage that I honestly thought
about not having her
um I I was about to make an appointment
and get you know go to the clinic
um but my
um my husband at the time he begged me
not to he made all these promises about
um you know this you know things would
get better and we're gonna be okay and
like you know don't you know don't do
this let's have our baby
so I said fine
at the time he was
working at like a home store and
he was cheating on me with one of the
girls that worked there
and uh just like he had done with all
the others he manipulated her and made
her think that like
um they were going to be together and
everything so she somehow
I found out that she was
um like stalking stalking us
um especially me so she found out that I
was pregnant
and so she would call me up and tell me
she was going to come over and like kick
me in the stomach and make me lose my
baby and she's gonna kill me and blow up
my house and everything like that
um
and so I didn't
that made me feel even worse because I
said to myself this guy
can't even control himself for nine
months
to to just not you know not be doing
what he was doing for nine months to let
me enjoy my pregnancy
um the harassment I changed my phone
number
um
she even this girl even came to our
house
um it got to the point where I had to
get a restraining order
um because I couldn't take it
um so six months pregnant I am at the
courthouse getting restraining order
against my husband's mistress
um because she was threatened to kill me
and my baby
so um
after that I had our daughter
I just kind of like
made her my focus like I said you know
I'm miserable but let me just focus on
her because I wanted her to have like a
normal life because I didn't have one
um so I just I really just you know
focused everything on her and I just uh
kind of went into survival mode and just
every day was the same
um
I had to like put the depression and
anxiety to the side to be a mom
um
during this time
my one of my younger adopted siblings
was still living at home with our
adopted dad
and um
she found out that he was molesting our
younger brother and she confronted him
and he went crazy
um she called the cops he went crazy
um pulled a gun on himself like he was
going to kill himself and uh
he ended up um so the cops came they
Baker acted him
as soon as he got out of the mental
hospital I I don't know why he wasn't
arrested then and there but he he wasn't
and he ended up taking off and going on
the run for years nobody knew where he
was
um at this time him and my adopted mom
had already separated and she moved to
uh Ocala to be with her family
and so um
we had to go to court we had to do um
we had to like give testimony and things
like that um while he was on the run and
this court case was open my adopted
brother ended up going into like a group
home
because of this and um
do all this my adopted mom never reached
out once and said are you okay I'm sorry
or or anything she just acted like
nothing was going on
and so um
you know he like I said he was on the
the run for for many many years um he
was literally on I think he was on
America's Most Wanted at one point
um because once my once it came out
about my brother my other siblings who
were also
um abused came forward too so he had
many charges against him
um so by this now around this time I was
working um for a large Cosmetics company
and
um I was doing really well I was like
feeling good about myself because like
people you know I had a lot of you know
clientele that loved me and I was great
at sales and you know it was like you
know my passion
and then um
eventually uh my adopted dad was caught
and um put in jail
I went to visit him a few times because
a part of me thought that this can't be
real this cannot be the dad that that
raised me because like I said my adopted
mom pure evil no no question about it
but he he didn't like I I never knew
anything was I never knew anything was
going on
um
he never to this day won't admit to it
um but he did end up
pleading guilty to some of the charges
and like going to to jail for I think it
was like eight or nine years
and now he lives in um
like a home for offenders like somewhere
in like North North Florida
and um that's what happened with him
my adopted mom eventually um
I think I saw her maybe once or twice
after that she she wouldn't talk about
anything she still never admitted to
anything and
that's fine
um
she about two years ago she actually
passed away from covid
um I hadn't seen her in many many years
and
I I know this sounds awful
but I wasn't that sad because
I just felt like she let so much happen
and she did so much herself and she
never paid for any of it or took
responsibility
so um
you know many many years went by and
you know I was raising my daughter and I
was still miserable
um I at that point I think I had just
become numb to
um my husband's behavior
um
because and I got tired of fighting back
because
he would get
he was mostly verbally abusive and like
mentally abusive
but he would get physical
the thing with the narcissist is the the
most important thing is keeping their
secrets so he would get physical when I
was coming close to like like finding
something out he couldn't deny
so for example
he always would have another phone like
always and I would like see it out of
the corner of my eye and he and I would
call him out on and he was like no
you're seeing things like that's not
what it was
so there was a time when my daughter was
probably three or four and his um his
son my stepson Jordan
um was visiting from Wisconsin
and uh
he was um in the bathroom like supposed
to be cleaning and I you know I walk
into the bathroom and he has a phone
I see him with the phone the other phone
and he like throws it in the drawer and
closes the door
and so I'm like I go in and I go to open
the drawer he got so angry that he
shoved me out of the bathroom into the
wall in the hallway
and I literally just crumpled to the
floor and was crying and he stepped over
me like a piece of garbage I'm laying on
the floor hysterical and he literally
stepped over me like I was a piece of
garbage
um this all happened in front of my
daughter and his son his son called
9-1-1 to try to protect me
the cops came and like so many abused
women do I covered for him
and then he told his son I'm ashamed of
you for doing that for calling the cops
on me and that broke my heart because he
was this little boy who shouldn't be
witnessing this was trying to protect me
needless to say after that Debbie never
sent him for a visit again and I don't
blame her
um
funny enough me and Debbie became really
good friends and I started confiding in
her and talking to her about everything
and you know she went through the same
thing with him so she understood more
than anyone
and she would offer to like help me to
get away from him and she's like you
know I did it you can do it and I just I
just wasn't strong enough
um
at one point we tried marriage
counseling
and um
he didn't he ended up not liking it
because the therapist saw right through
him and we would do
um individual counseling and like
couples counseling and one day the last
time I went to that that appointment
um with with the therapist she said to
me she's like this is she's like I'm
taking off my professional hat and she
said to me
he will never change he does not care he
sees no problem with the things that
he's doing if you want to leave him I
have resources I will help you leave him
the therapist said that to me
um
but like I said because he saw that like
he couldn't manipulate the therapist
um he cut off like he canceled the
session so we weren't going anymore
so this went on for a really long time
um
I would go to work with uh black eyes
and
a lot of people kind of knew what was
going on so they you know
they wouldn't even question it I would
go to work with a black eye and they
would just sit me down and like help me
cover it so I could work like it was
just
it was so sad and um
I at one point even became anorexic
because they say
you know when you can't control you know
control your life people that develop
Eating Disorders it's because
um that's the only thing they can
control
so I became anorexic for a really long
time and at one point I was literally a
hundred pounds and I was like a skeleton
I was sick all the time I had no energy
I would like just randomly pass out
um
and even seeing me like that he um
like instead of trying to to get me help
or
um put me in some type of a program he
would say you know look at you like when
you bend over I can see your spine
that's disgusting like you know
things like that
um
but kind of like my family to the
outside looking in we were this normal
couple
um
he would uh buy me gifts and things like
that you know I guess to make up for
everything he was doing but he's the
type of person whereas if he does
something nice for you he wants everyone
to know
so if we went out to dinner you know
with friends he'd be like oh you know
Deanna did you show everyone the ring I
bought you did you show everyone the
purse I got you you know it was it was
always things like that he was always
worried about appearances he always had
to be better than everyone else
um
Hurricane Wilma
um had destroyed our house destroyed it
so when we got insurance money to fix it
um you know he was telling our you know
our friends about you know how we're you
know redoing the house and everything
and I was like yeah you know we you know
because of Wilma we got insurance money
I got scolded when we got home because
he says why did you tell people we fixed
it because of Wilma like why are you
telling people were only doing it
because we got insurance money because
he wanted people to think that he had
all this money and we were just you know
randomly redoing our entire house like
everything was about appearances
um
so I just kind of uh just I got to the
point where I just said I guess this is
just my life like this is it
um I have to at least stick it out until
my daughter is is 18 and then maybe I
can get out of this because my whole
thing was I wanted her to have the
normal life that I didn't have
which is a lot of mistakes that which is
a big mistake that I think a lot of
women make because
they don't realize that the kids get to
the point where they know what's going
on you're not giving them a normal life
you're showing them that this is okay to
accept
so the last straw for me
um I had over the years tried to leave
him um it never worked out like they say
of huge women I think it takes like an
average of eight times to to Really
Leave
but the last straw for me was
and then another thing that I want to
say is
it's it bothers me when um people are
like oh you know just leave and just get
out of it and you know like it's so easy
um you don't let me tell you you do not
leave a narcissist you do not just leave
a narcissist
so um
when my daughter was probably nine or
ten years old she had a breakdown and
she said mom she's like I have to tell
you something and I don't want you to
get upset at me
but I have to tell you like what's going
on I said what's going on
so she tells me that he's been taking
her
um around other women and telling her to
lie to me about it
um
you know telling me you know telling her
to say oh you know we were we were um we
went here we went there
um just making you know it was eating
her up inside that he was making her
life for him
um
and so she told me and she's like um
and then she said and he has I can tell
you where his other phone is she's like
I know you know he has another phone
I'll tell you where it is and I know the
code because my daughter's smart she
sees she sees everything
and so she told me where it was
I got it and I knew if he caught me with
it it would be like I I wasn't gonna
deal with um I didn't want to deal with
what he would do if he caught me with it
so I told he was home at the time he was
doing like some work outside and so I
told her mommy is going to take a drive
I will be right back
so I got in my car
and I drove to like some parking lot I I
went into the phone and
the the things I I saw on that phone
were just vile like
the the you know the things he was
telling other women
um
the you know there were there were times
when he said he was literally at a
funeral and he was at a hotel room with
another woman
he um
he had a he would take you know pictures
of you know their sexual acts like I I
could not believe what I was seeing in
the phone
so
he finally realizes that I'm gone and he
calls me and he's like you know where
are you and I said oh I'm sitting in the
in the parking lot
um and at this point I think I think
having concrete poop kind of made me
stronger because he couldn't tell me
anymore like oh that's not happening
that's not what's going on and you know
everything
so I said to him I said I'm in the
parking lot looking at your phone he
said what do you mean my phone I'm like
your phone and he goes he got real
serious like he would be he would be so
cocky and then he he got real serious he
was like well you don't know the code I
said yes I do and I told him the code
he immediately
called the phone company and as I'm
holding the phone it it clears out and
he wiped the phone he called and like
wiped the phone
um but I had already made sure I like
took with my phone I had taken pictures
I had sent myself stuff so you know
whatever
so I go back home and I tell him I'm
like listen I said I don't care that you
wiped the phone like I want you to know
that I'm done like I mean at this time
this is over I'm done you brought our
kid I said I could deal with the things
that you're doing but the fact that you
brought our child into it and made her
lie to her mother I said now I'm done I
said because the only reason I'm still
with you is because I wanted her to have
a better life
um
so he ended up
getting mad at my daughter you know mad
at our daughter
um for telling the truth because they
don't like the truth to come out ever
and uh I tried to take her and leave and
he he held me hostage in the house with
her he took away the car he took my car
keys he took our phones he took her iPad
um and he would not let me leave
um
so I ended up having to you know stay
you know stay the night
and uh the next day he went to work and
I called him and I said just so you know
I'm not like this is serious like I'm
done like I don't want to be in this
anymore I I'm done and he you know
and uh
he he uh this was when things really got
crazy when he knew like we were done
so
he knew I was serious and um
so I I had friends that were kind of
trying to help me and
um he started basically
um
he started stalking me at that point so
uh I guess he must have had either
tracker on my phone or in the car or
whatever so one day um I was I wasn't
answering his calls or anything and he
he went to where I was and um when I
came out into the parking lot he had
been sitting in my car because he had a
kid in my car so he was sitting in my
car
in the dark and when I got in the car
he he started screaming at me so I you
know I jumped out of the car and he's
literally attacking me in the parking
lot um
and when I try to jump in my car and
started to leave he had unplugged the
battery so I couldn't start the car
and so the cops came and you know we had
to do a police report and everything
um there was another incident where
he must have left his car somewhere else
and uh when I had uh got home one day
with our you know with our daughter I
had like coffee and stuff and the house
was dead quiet and my daughter goes mom
I hear something weird like someone's in
the house and and she go and he and uh
I'm like you know what just as I say
what I turn and he comes barreling out
of the hallway and like grabs me and the
coffee and everything you know steaming
hot coffee all over me my daughter's
screaming he's calling me every name in
the book where were you you [__] you
[__] like who do you think you are like
how dare you like not answer my calls
and everything so at that point I knew I
was gonna have to get to get through
this I was gonna have to get a
restraining order
and so um
he also at this point had uh turned off
all my credit cards pulled all the money
out of our joint banking account and um
wouldn't let me have access to any money
um so I had to um
I I felt like I was preparing for a
storm which I literally was so before he
had done that I went and bought like
everything we would need for the house
because I was even though I was working
he made a lot more than me so I was
dependent on him and he knew that so I
went and bought like basic necessities
food toilet paper laundry detergent soap
like you know all these things that kind
of stocked up so when he found out I had
went and filed the restraining order
I wasn't um I wasn't home at the time so
he went into the house like and I had
changed the locks already
um because I knew they were going to be
serving him that day
he uh he broke into the house took
everything that I had uh bought to you
know take care of me and my daughter for
the next however long
um so I I got to the house he was in
there like taking everything out uh the
cops came and um literally had to tell
him like put some of the stuff out he
was taking out all the TVs and like
everything because you know he wanted to
punish me for for leaving him
um so they let him get his things and
left and you know let him leave and uh
when they wouldn't let me in the house
while he was in there so once he left I
went into the house
he along with his stuff he made sure he
took you know every piece of jewelry he
bought me
um my computer I my iPad uh you know
most of the TVs you know because he
wanted to punish me
um then he called and now he knew I was
living there with you know with our
daughter
and I didn't have any money because he
had taken everything he turned off our
power he turned off
um our cell phones not only turned off
our cell phones but called and
reported them stolen so that I couldn't
go and get them turned back on
um so I was very
I was um
I started having doubts like is this
really worth it like going through all
this to to be free of this person
um so I ended up calling attorneys and
most of them when I told them my
situation their answer was well how are
you going to pay me then like you don't
have any money how are you gonna pay me
but uh I eventually called this one
attorney same as actually Mark Mark Bain
and uh he took the time and listened to
my story and gave me advice and told me
like you know
you know if you can get together even
this amount of money I'll start the the
paperwork for you so
um
we ended up doing that uh
the divorce was you know it was hard um
he fought me on everything every step of
the way
um
but eventually I did I did make it
through it and
we got our divorce and um
eventually I you know I did drop the
restraining order and I tried to
kind of like co-parent with him and
um
because he wasn't
like he he doesn't like being told what
to do so he wouldn't keep up with like
the schedule like you know the
visitation schedule and uh you know
everything and so I tried to like um
co-parent with him and uh we would have
times when we would get get along and
then times where he once again would
just be verbally abusive and nasty and
um I even tried taking him to um
to a therapist so we could learn to like
so we could talk calmly in a safe place
with a like a mediator and learn how to
co-parent and even that therapist after
a few sessions said don't bring him here
anymore he doesn't get it he doesn't
want to change there's there's no point
so just you know stop
um
so uh
that was basically
um in 2016 uh when we divorced and um
it's just you know it's been me and my
daughter and uh
I'm in a relationship now that you know
you know and the person like loves me
and supports me and and everything and
it's taken a lot of therapy to
to uh work through like everything I've
been through and um
to learn to like you know forgive myself
and
to forgive like
you know
you do you really do have to learn to
forgive people that that aren't sorry
you have to accept that you're not going
to get a story you have to just forgive
them and move on with your life
and so that's you know kind of where I'm
at now um I've had to you know after my
divorce my credit was destroyed I had
nothing I had you know barely anything
and um I've rebuilt my life I
um
I help uh run a you know run a business
I have my own business
um I just bought my first brand new car
on my own which I was just
for most people that's that's not a big
deal but for me like I never thought I
would get to that point where I could do
something like that on my own and
um my daughter our daughter is 16 now
and uh unfortunately she doesn't really
have much of a relationship with him and
that's taken a toll on her as well
um so
like all I want to do now is just raise
her to
to you know my focus now is just you
know to continue to improve our lives
and to raise her to love herself and
you know know how valued she is so she
doesn't have to end up like me and think
that that's what she has to settle for
and accept and that's where I'm at did
you feel like the the childhood you had
is kind of what set you up for being
yeah absolutely absolutely
yeah because like I said like my my
adopted mom was you know was a
narcissist and my um
so like being with with him like it kind
of was like I was used to that I was
used to that treatment I was used to
being put down and not made to feel good
about myself and then the fact that I
really at that time wasn't educated and
I had no family to fall back on like I
had no I felt like I kind of had no
choice but to stay in that situation
um
oh I I also I should have mentioned this
before
um my my biological mom after not
speaking to her for years
uh I got a phone call at like three in
the morning one day and when I saw who
it was my aunt calling I already knew
why she was calling
um my mother had uh at like 55
7 years old
um she had overdosed and um passed away
and um I found out later and it really
broke my heart because she was on um
methadone she was trying to get better
but I guess when you're on methadone
it's hard to to get high so she had she
was just still trying to get high and
she just overdid it and
um she passed away and that you know
that really took a toll on me as well
um unless I never got to have that
relationship that I wanted to have with
her but
um I forgave her because I knew that
you know addiction is
addiction ruins people and it takes
presence over everything and I know that
she wasn't like that because she wanted
to be
um it's because she just couldn't she
couldn't stop and um I've had to like
accept that and know that like it's not
it wasn't my fault
um
and uh like like you had said like I do
feel like I kind of
my childhood didn't make me end up in
that situation because when you think
about it my own biological parents
didn't want me the parents that chose to
adopt me abused you know abused us and
treated us like garbage and taught us to
be ashamed of who we are and then you
know my ex-husband like he treated me
the same so I'm like this is just I I
it's like this is just my life like I'm
not a valuable person I'm not a
beautiful person I'm just this is all I
am is someone for people to walk on and
abuse and that's just who I am in this
world and I for a long time I accepted
that is it changing now with your new
relationship it is that's great it is
and lots of therapy you deserve it thank
you you deserve thank you you deserve to
be happy thank you I'm trying
all right Deanna thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
for having me very interesting thank you
thank you